au début quand les deux sont en pleine
ascension c'est très facile ah ouais
quand ça marche bien pour les deux oui
c'est pas de problème dès qu'il ya un
petit décalage très belles photos ray
dès qu'il ya un petit décalage
est bien là où dès que ça va moins bien
ça commence à avoir des trous et des
frictions et en fait ce qui est terrible
c'est que dans mon cas c'était tellement
fort on arrivait à laisser passer tous
les quinze jours on avait les 4 5 une
c'est tellement fort qu on arrive
tellement aux câpres et paf ça ouais
c'est vrai celle ci je sais que je suis
à présent ils ont parlé avec des
trémolos dans la voix mais on a oublié
parce que moi et moi je suis déçu bien
sûr mais l'important c'est que ma grand
mère disait ne plus aimer c'est facile
ne pas sourire c'est compliqué thébaux
est devenu commerçant c'est faire un bon
café
[Rires]
on l'a oublié mais diego ce qu'elle a
dit votre grand mère c'est le coup comme
vos grands parents et beaux-parents
blanche comme ça plus on avance plus ça
défoule c'est tout cas non mais c'est
fou comme quoi quand et bien c'est vrai
que cuit a démarré très haut chez vous
et non mais il en reste encore un petit
peu benjamin et je le dis toujours très
intelligent très cultivé et vraiment
bravo je ne sais pas ce que j'admire et
valérie non mais je disais on a oublié à
quel point benjamin et flavie ça a été
un truc de dingue dans la peinture il y
avait tous les jours une gala paris
match voici tout tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps on a oublié aussi
leur mariage qui était survolée par
hélicoptère les gendarmes avaient fermé
des routes dans un chacun ajouté un truc
tellement cette défaite - quote on se
dit tout ça pour ça
et
je le disait encore hier il n'y a plus
de stars de télé non franchement y'a
plus d'animateurs star involontaire si
c'est vrai ça franchement bas que nous
avons depuis l'apogée les piles à
patrick sébastien et puis là y'a plus la
télé créé plus de stars mais c'est satan
là y'a plus que vous n'en avez là plus
que vous et non mais des gens comme ça
qu'on est non mais à plus de stars c'est
vrai il y avait une volonté des chaînes
avant il y avait tf1 c'était la chaîne
des stars m6 la chaîne déprogramme et m6
miser là dessus en disant c'est le
programme plus fort que l'animateur
alors que tf1 disait c'est l'animateur
qui est plus fort que le programme est
aujourd'hui ça s'est amusé et moi et moi
je dis souvent les chroniqueurs sont
plus forts que l'animateur c'est la
faute des 6-13 ans non même si
s'arrêtait une critique qui est pas une
si je ne les avais pas m6 mais c'est
vrai que c'est original et maintenant
ils ont été malins parce qu'il s'en sort
tout seul et je peux vous dire que à la
fin d'année ils sont contents dans sa
politique d un animateur vieillit mal un
programme peut vieillir audit c'est très
bien mais à gambetta ouais mais bon mais
moi j'ai démarre à 12 ans
non mais la foule de m6 aussi c'est de
faire des programmes qui sont des
programmes miroir c'est à dire que on
sait pas c'est pas une vedette qui
présente c'est déjà fait ça et ses girls
next door où est
le problème est si précis parce que
c'est dur de sortir avec une star quand
on est à des problèmes d'ego daniel mon
vous vous êtes partagés pastor j'avais
18 ans donc je sais peut-être
elle est sortie avec la douce acteurs
très très très très très connu et même
vous les plus jeunes vous devez
connaître
moi j'ai zéro découvert à la passe que
des trucs en noir et blanc l'a
déjà vu des films muets
il y avait des acteurs j'ai jamais
entendu leur voie privée donc mais cette
année c'est vrai non c'est pas charles
même si celui avec qui elle est sortie d
une très belle can
daniel pour nos téléspectateurs un juste
un indice bah vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure c'est des acteurs comiques je ne
dirais pas qu'ils ont tourné dans de
nombreux films à oui oui ouais exactes
sur le feu hamon alors là vous le dire
c'est pas alain delon
voilà c'est pas dessus dans le de ce
calibre là vous le savez vous oui moi je
le sais gbagbo dit tout bien sûr c'est
mon avis elle parce que j'ai confiance
mais dit voilà je ne le dirai jamais à
même pas là tout de suite
la non moins de 300 euros c'est fait
après moi je pense que les vrais stars
j'ai pas à l'époque que vanessa paradis
johnny depp nicole kidman tom cruise ça
doit être invivable parce qu'ils doivent
être traqués il doit y avoir des
histoires d'ego de max de notoriété de
jalousie par ce projet moi c'est pas sur
ce projet c'est leur hymne aux oscars
moi je suis pas nommé en valeur donc ça
doit être invivable il y a que des des
stars qui tiennent ensemble en couple
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de business il
ya de l'argent les beckham par exemple
on sait qu'ils tiennent visible parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent il a créé mon
avis il va lancer ça tient parce qu'il
ya trop de il ya trop d'intérêts
financiers entre mais alors et puis même
des couples fort gap jean dujardin par
exemple quand il a été nommé aux oscars
le le couple a complètement lâché je ne
connais pas ce garçon déjà réalisé alors
goûter hyper société est l'amour de ma
mère est ce que j'ai le contraire non je
ne permets pas que tu es dont je ne
connais pas les gens je l adore voilà
c'est tout mou et tous les gens aiment
bien sûr avaya vécu même sur les tonga
moi j'ai en boîte qui était vraiment
assistons là sur un film mahir
franchement jean dujardin mais quel
amour ce mec et voilà après c'est
peut-être le la distance aussi la
distance avec ses musiciens vous êtes ça
vous êtes la femme de jean dujardin il
est sollicité par tous et vous vous êtes
sorti avec quelqu'un de connu on va pas
se mentir vous avez même fait la une de
voici ne mentez pas oui parce que c'est
compliqué alors mesdames mais même nom
mais même avant déjà mais avant un
comédien me dira pas qui y changera pas
c'est alors je te disais
je te dit daniel moreira parce qu'on
peut aller sans nom je change pas on le
fait qu'au quotidien
c'est pas les boîtes
jedox et paktia débat jean lefebvre n'a
pas parlé mais c'est juste pour te dire
mais il a inachevé dans quoi non mais
c'est vrai
[Musique]
qu'il n'a pas explosé non monsieur
bahreïn et enfin un échange
je te tueras pas bien trempé aux
victoires des champions où il tend est
enfoui vol non autonomes sur un papier
tu me le naturel non non non non non non
non mais ce que je peux pas non non moi
j'ai confiance en vous mais si vous lui
dites mathieu il va le dire c'est une
pipelette il ne m'attends moi moi moi
moi c'est pas pareil mois il vient
encore allaités darry cowl ou je sais
pas quoi
[Applaudissements]
nicchi
[Rires]
mais non c'est bon
mais c'est pas du tout darry cowl
élancé daddy cool
ça le mec d c'est le mec de bonheur
non est ce qui était dû à ce genre oui
voilà non mais peu importe le nom moi
mais c'était au moment où ils s'étaient
les les anges démarré tout ça ça parait
qu on met du coup moi j'avais quasiment
rien fait avant tellement vrai ça marche
vous dire
d'accord c'est une grande carrière
matinée je continue à faire de merde
alors et du coup les les ans j'arrivais
tout ça nrj 12 le mcs commence à marcher
et deux mois du coup bah voilà j'avais
30 ans de ça c'était hyper sollicitées
boîte de nuit les mâles samedi comment
ça va et l'eau jaillit site passé rire
au théâtre espace et rien ne se passait
rien moi j'arrivais le soir il est du
coup forcément tu as 30 ans tentent de
sortir tu m'a coûté le plus beau tout le
monde trouve formidable ont dit oui à
tout tu vois et était très sollicité et
effectivement ce que des escrocs disait
benjamin il ya un moment où si la
cailleret pas au même niveau
sa classe de lego et tout ça ça clashe
claque assurée april vous qui se
démarque c'est vrai non mais si oui non
moi je pense que ça doit être plus
fertiles parce que la personne doit vous
comprendre sur les buzz sur la
médiatisation alors elle est fraîche
encore la bouche sur huit mois la vie
moi je pense qu'elle a raison dans le
même milieu il fait qu'en voiture si
elle n'est pas du tout connu
donc vous êtes en train de dire
peut-être enfin de faire tout
ce qu'il ya sacha le base
sur l'année cela d'achat des passagers
face à challes bave mais vous par
exemple vous aimeriez être avec une star
de cinéma où je
passais une grande notoriété à vous
aussi avez margot robbie sur le coup
maintenant elle était sur moi
aimerions une actrice américaine mais
c'est franchir le pas hollywood et
surtout apprendre l'anglais a lâché
c'est vous dire c'est pas en allongeant
quelqu'un tu apprends que vous devriez
mal oui le fait que votre compagne mais
ils soient plus connu que vous
nationalement ce que plus riches c'est
pas possible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
wade voit rihanna si elle veut salins
j'aime bien y en a mais c'est plausible
est connu que supporter mais alors oui
ça me gêne pas du tout moi elle peut
être plus connu que moi plus riche que
moi voilà mais je m'en fous total moi la
seule chose que je demande c'est qu'elle
espère aller faire mon pad le dimanche
ça ne s'est pas compliqué de merde qui
sort avec quelqu'un de connu comment va
se remettre des lots est connue d'un
comme lé coni m'a alors j'espère vous
êtes tous les deux dans la rue reconnaît
plus qui souvent les hommes daniel et
puis
les femmes moi non des hommes après ils
font de ces géraldine un petit peu ouais
non en fait ça dépend mais les gens sont
très gentils sera laissée
bah oui mais n'a pas expliqué d'être
avec quelqu'un et des douves vous soyez
que tous les deux connus non parce qu'en
fait on est dans des milieux très
différents et moi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui donc plus il est
connu à puis je suis content de revenir
way élus les blinds oui je pense assez
beau
couple quoi et vous avec patoche qui est
très connu dans le milieu comme on est
bien sûr il un quoi on sait qu'on est
venu tard on est vieux soir il est connu
à 50 arrêts seront connus à raison tant
à 25 cantons exploitants on a eu plein
de vie avant donc de les faire craquer
même que benhaim 30 ans de télé avant
patoche n'a jamais fricot dès qu'un
animateur accès manger alors c'est pas
moi je savais que des mariés on m'a dit
avec mon mari on m'a dit qu'il y avait
un bail avec bataille et fontaine les
deux
médaillés me répondait y'a que la vérité
qui compte en revanche
[Rires]
et alors non mais c'est vrai oui c'est
faux kastali vous avez pécho kid connu à
part je vais vous répondre
que l'animatrice non mais on animateurs
c'est quelque chose ou alors
américaine
des actrices avec déjà 10 20 fois
mcdonald's
mcd.n il est vraiment avec andy mcdonald
l'atide ronald
oui pas longtemps et sortir andy
macdowell
et la sûreté des cuves et en pensent les
hommes il ya une chanteuse et une
chanteuse américaine connue vas-y partie
des spice girls
a dit van fois échoué c'est du temps de
guînes mais oui oui mais albi ouais même
si celle ci
avec médecine bien sûr j'aurais très
sympa d'ailleurs c'est pas vrai il était
venu chez drucker est reparti avec moi
non
et ouais parce que d'enquêter sur le
coup
[Applaudissements]